so here we are we're in addis ababa um
and as you can see we're getting lots of
local culture here and we're here for a
project to actually help with physics
training physics teaching
we're here for a joint project all about
physics teaching and over here we have
all the other people involved in the
project
we have two representatives from the
institute of physics who've been here a
number of times before bill poole and
christine cleave and then we've got
jared emma
jeremy antigua
we arrived here on friday we were fairly
tired so we spent most of the day
looking around various different
historical sites in addis ababa
so
the food
reservation room but i guess maybe it's
food preservation room these hooks are
used to store slabs over to hang up
slabs of raw meat and that raw meat is
actually eaten raw as well so it's um
culturally it's very very interesting
it's really amazing really really
fantastic
beautiful view behind us so tomorrow we
will head down south of addis ababa to a
place called adama and that's where the
physics teacher training is going to
happen and
i'm sure sean is going to be filming us
along the way this me for me
come next year okay okay go over here
he reckons it's a fantastic view from
down here
wow
wow
wow what's your name
beautiful thank you
thank you
so mulaka here has um
taken us down to to a place where
there's just an absolutely astounding
view right across addis ababa in the
distance and just the wonderful
beautiful beautiful landscape it's
fantastic i'm a bit exhausted after
trying to keep my balance going down
there but it's it's it's a really really
impressive view thank you thanks malaku
oh it's damn good
we've arrived at goro i'll try and get
the pronunciation apparently you're
meant to really are i'm not very good at
rolling ours
um can barely pronounce ours at the best
of time but here yeah as you can see at
preparatory school this is why we're
here to do a training course for you can
see the teachers who are all around and
we're going to be involved in sharing
what we do in terms of experimental
physics and you know i'm sure we'll get
some insights from them as well in terms
of how they teach physics
what's remarkable is that the teachers
have come from 11 different regions some
of them as as far away as 1 000
kilometers or maybe even 1500 kilometers
so it's it's a big event for them and
it's a big event for us as well
no pressure no pressure at all no show
and absolutely no pressure
important thing here is that richard
feynman was a theoretician so he writes
down his theories
and then people who do experiments come
along and check his theories
for
for me
when we plot experimental data we plot
it as points we don't join up the dots
because there are no measurements
between those points so we plot the
points and then we draw a fit line
through those points and
it's it's a bit of a bug bear of mine
it's a minor thing but a bit of a bug
so it's going really really well this
morning we did a number of presentations
just about the scientific method about
the experimental methods in general we
did a really nice session on hooke's law
which is really straightforward just a
mass on the end of a spring measuring
the extension and getting in the ideas
of plotting a graph etc and then we also
did a another really nice experiment was
little cars going down the slope in
terms of acceleration and thinking about
how we plotted graph to work out the
acceleration now we're playing with
slinkies and we're going to wander
upstairs and see exactly what they're
doing with slinkies
this side
it reflects back on the other side so
i'm just really really impressed by how
christine is putting this across just in
terms of longitudinal transverse worlds
concept of energy and how the speed
changes with the the mass per unit
attention
we are going to
try and repeat the wonderful slinky
experiments that christine did we swap
rounds so we demonstrate different
experiments throughout the day and at
the moment i'm unraveling a slinky and
i'm finally nearly about to how do you
disentangle this bloody thing
do you know how amazing i was saying
slinkies were before shown yeah they're
not
watch how long it takes for this pulse
to die down
it keeps going keeps going keeps going
keeps going keeps going
as soon as you give it to a student like
me
one of the problems in our schools that
teachers are always waiting
for
ready-made materials but from this
we can understand that teachers if they
are interested they can do a lot of
activities with the materials available
in their survival yeah water bottles
string stones they can all be used
absolutely
what's the best thing you've done so far
the best thing the best thing yeah
just enjoying this doing experiments
we can work out how thick this line is
in terms of the area so how many layers
of atoms there are
on this
page
so what you do when you make these
measurements it's essential that you for
example hold it and then
do that make one measurement
make another measurement
make another picture at least three
measures
it's going okay i think there was some
confusion at the start i don't think i
explained it quite as well like they
didn't quite get the point
to it so i had to explain a couple of
times why we're plotting the graph and
not just calculating the values but
they're getting on with it and they're
getting the practice and that's the
important thing
the wetness of the material is going to
represent its temperature
so we are transferring the water into
the sponge so the equivalent of
transferring the
heat energy into the material
i am an electron in the valence band
i can't go anywhere
they're all in the way
there's no way i can get i can go
if i'm here no electrons
i'm free to move
so three measurements is okay five
measurements is good
ten is even better have you done
anything like this before
so it's the end of the second day it's
i'm fairly tired the rest of us are
fairly tired but it's such a such a
privilege to be here the enthusiasm the
love of learning the love of knowledge
is fantastic being asked so many
questions emma's experiment on graphite
went particularly well tiago's
experiment went well jeremy's been
having fun so much fun playing around
with electronics which he loves and
jared's enthusiastically helping out
right across the board it's wonderful
here um the heat is oppressive
i sweat all the time
um
and when you're continually
concentrating and running from place to
place all day it can be quite exhausting
but it's a good type of exhaustion and
when you get to the end of the day yeah
you know it's been it's been good i
think we've achieved something so it's a
lot of the time have to shout above the
din of this in the background but um
that's no bad thing
do
we're going to do two notes a really low
one and a really high one do your best
everybody do it together and then
everybody will be happy so let's go
okay not good enough not good enough
let's change the scale again
one last goal
three
two
one
right now i'm gonna go as high as i can
right that was not good let's try it
again
not bad thank you very much
we know that magnetic field lines means
a line that presents
the magnetic field strength around a
magnet
can everyone see
can you see can you see the water hair
or clothes
yeah
yeah you see
the brush inside here and the difference
of the environmental pressure
so 6.6
ten point five
so we've now got to the end of the
training course at odama we're traveling
back from adama to addis and we've
stopped midway between the dharmaradas
it's absolutely stunning absolutely
beautiful you can hear
you listen as well
delighted at how well the course has
gone but rather disappointed that i
missed the last two days of it because i
was rather ill it's just fantastic here
it's just sort of everything you think
africa would be jeremy here is
paddling away
and driving us in roughly the right
direction
we've had such a great time exploring
the environment here it's just it's just
amazing absolutely amazing
so it's come to an end we're flying home
we're all extremely knackered extremely
exhausted
it's been
immensely fun it's been immensely
um enjoyable i hope what we've done has
been worthwhile we certainly want to
continue links i think the teachers got
a lot out of it the only disappointment
for me was because i got sick i really
wish that hadn't happened and i've also
mucked up sean's continuity because i've
had a shave really sorry about that but
my face was so sweaty i had to have a
shave
anyway
going home i'll miss ethiopia but i must
admit what i won't miss mosquitoes
really won't miss the mosquitoes
everyone's finishing and they need to do
more we're gonna need more elements 13
months
so it's aluminium sunshine then yeah
aluminium is 13 because there are 13
months in the ethiopian calendar